Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr?
It's time for the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
February 11th,
2019.
What is going on with you?
How are you [inaudible] I am actually recording part of this anyways,
I'll rerecording here Saturday night cause I'm out of your tour and doing a
little bit of stand up and just when I have to fly on Sunday and then I got a
fucking bunch of Shit I have to do Monday.
I gotta I gotta do this in spurts.
They got to do a couple of rounds here.
You know,
it's weird.
I've been walking around today all by myself,
all by my lonesome and uh,
for some reason I don't know why this fucking melody with the wrong lyrics has
been stuck in my head.
I just been walking around going Sherry's berries.
Why your bug and
makes no fucking sense whatsoever.
Yeah.
I never had a song.
I always had a song for me undies beyond Ds.
So Sherry's berries
keeps that they might advertise this far.
Can we go?
I have no idea.
I'm doing this so early.
I don't even have the advertising yet.
You understand?
Do you understand how dangerous a podcast this is right now?
Um,
any ways,
any way.
I guess as I've been told I'm supposed to stay and said anyways.
Anyway,
I'm fucking,
uh,
I did my first standup road gig in,
in since I came back from Europe,
uh,
ended the acting Gig and I walked out on stage,
got on the fucking bicycle and it was a,
it was all right.
Everything went great.
I want to thank everybody came out to the bore,
got up in Atlantic city.
I had a great fucking time.
And uh,
now I'm sort of barnstorming around just doing some like,
you know,
clubs and local areas in shit.
Just doing the hour and trying to figure out how I'm going to put this fucking
thing together.
Uh,
whittled some shit down,
get in,
get out,
take this fucking thing and then move on to my next hour.
My favorite fucking thing to do,
my favorite fucking thing to do is,
is the,
is the day after the special when all that material is flushed down the fucking
toilet and I get to start over again.
No fucking pressure.
You know?
Yeah.
The precious to special.
Once you get the special done,
you know,
if you're like me,
you're going to continue to like fuck up in life.
So the material is going to come,
you know,
speaking of fucking up,
I was staying in this hotel about a week ago.
I forgot to tell you the story.
What's the fucking,
I swear to God,
like the level
of like hostile
that corporations have got to as far as just complete lack of customer.
He can't get anybody on the fucking phone.
Total skeleton crew,
go fuck yourself.
The the,
the way this does shit is now,
you know what I mean?
Like if you have a problem with you fucking iPhone,
who the hell are you going to call?
How the fuck you going to get anybody on the phone
or at least somebody from in this fucking atmosphere,
you can't do it.
Right.
So last couple of hotels I stayed in,
right.
I go to call room service.
How long should that take?
Two.
Three fucking rings.
Worst case scenario,
they usually have an outgoing message going like,
hey,
be reaches message.
Just leave your room number and we will,
uh,
we'll call you right back and we'll figure out what,
what,
whatever you want,
right?
So
I'm fucking call this the Goddamn thing rings three times.
Puts me on hold.
I put it on speaker.
I'm sitting there for like 15 fucking minutes.
So I hang up.
I'm like,
all right,
so I fucking call the front desk.
And I was like,
yeah,
Hey,
I'm trying to order the Reuben
Reuben Sandwich there,
right?
I can't get through and nobody's picking up.
So the lady at the front desk is like,
oh,
that's strange.
Here,
let me,
I'll put you right through.
Puts me through to the same extension.
I'm back on hold again,
listening to the same fucking music.
Sit there again for another 10 minutes now about 25 minutes into trying to order
a fucking sandwich.
All right?
So then I go,
I have,
fuck this.
I go to the next one.
I call customer service is a customer service button.
Sony picks up after three rings.
I tell them what the fucking problem is.
He said,
oh my God,
it's terrible.
I'm so sorry.
Mr [inaudible].
Uh,
you know,
I'll,
let me,
let,
let me get you through.
I'll stay on with you,
right?
Same fucking extension.
Same fucking on hold music.
And I'm sitting there for like 15 seconds and I'm like,
wait.
I'm like,
dude,
are you still there?
He wasn't there,
so I fucking call back customer service again.
Somebody else picks up.
I see.
I tell the whole fucking story.
They just told you,
it's like the ninth time I'm telling this story.
I feel front desk,
the fucking cut.
Third time.
Right.
And as I'm telling him,
she goes,
he didn't stay on with you.
And I'm like,
no,
like,
is that normal behavior?
She goes,
I'm sorry.
All right,
let me get you through.
And she finally gets me through okay.
To Room Service.
It rings in the guy on the other end,
picks up room service and just goes,
hello?
I'm like,
yeah,
a is this room service?
He's like,
yeah,
okay.
I'm like,
ah,
I'd like to order some food to the room.
It's like super awkward.
And he goes,
all right.
I go,
okay,
can I get that Reuben Sandwich?
He's like,
Yep.
I go,
all right,
can I get a side salad instead of the fries?
Is it all right if I get a salad instead of the fries?
And he goes,
no
flat out says no.
Now what am I going to do?
Complained to him.
He's got my food,
he's got me by the balls.
So I was like,
I,
you know,
I guess I'm eating fries.
He's like,
well,
what do you want?
What do you want to drink?
I just go,
let me get a water with ice.
So he goes,
all right,
so you know,
I get in the room number and I fucking hang up.
And then I just sit there and walk around with fucking hotel room,
muttering to myself,
go on.
It literally took me a fucking half hour
to get through to somebody that could get me to somebody to order a fucking
sandwich to my room.
And,
and then when I asked,
you know,
have it your way,
Burger King,
he basically was like,
yeah,
no,
go.
Fuck.
He's like,
I was as kid,
Daddy,
can we get some ice cream now?
All right.
I guess you're taller than me and you're driving and you're paying for
everything.
So I guess what you say goes,
this guy's fucking talking to me like that.
So now I'm in another hotel
and uh,
I wanted to find out,
I don't know what,
there was a vending machine on this fucking floor and I'm trying to fuck,
there's no button on the phone that says front desk.
And this is feeling like a trend where I've noticed,
you know,
you go into your room,
if there's no menu,
you call him up.
If you can get somebody on the phone,
where's the menu?
They say it's on your TV and then you go on the TV and you got to use,
figure out your fucking remote control.
It's all on you.
You have to figure it out,
right?
And you've got to figure this shit out and then order it without talking to
anybody.
Um,
like how far are they going to take this?
I feel like in the future,
like you're going to be like,
especially in this country with the fucking healthcare,
you're going to be like dying or something and it's going to be up to you to
figure out like how to get ahold of somebody
and I don't know what you know if,
yeah.
Yeah.
Hey,
uh,
I got stabbed in the abdomen.
Okay.
Yeah,
as one.
If I could get some,
uh,
room service.
If you could like drive an ambulance over here.
Maybe like pick me up.
I,
yeah.
Can you,
uh,
you know,
maybe bring like some bandages and stuff?
No.
All right.
Well it was the ambulance going to show up.
Yeah,
that right.
That's going to be like,
like that level of shit.
I Dunno.
My fucking pet peeve though is people that hate their fucking job,
you know what I mean?
And then they take it out on you.
It's like,
dude,
it's not my fucking fault.
You work here.
Okay.
You don't like the job?
Quit.
I had shit jobs and I fucking,
I destroyed.
You know the fuck are you doing?
You're going to try,
when you get your dream job,
go fuck yourself.
You're going to suck the whole thing.
Oh Man.
Oh,
I got another good one.
I hope.
I'm assuming you enjoyed that story is another travel story for you.
So I'm on my way to Atlantic city,
right.
And I uh,
I get on the plane and I'm sitting there and I just,
as I'm sitting there,
I'm looking down.
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing reading a magazine or some shit.
And uh,
I was reading rolling stone.
Any of this guy going,
Bill Burr,
bill a bill,
Bill Burr.
Hey Bill.
Bill Burn and look up.
I see it's this comic.
I know my God.
Shit.
Hey,
how you doing?
He's like,
you work in Philly.
I was like,
no,
I'm landed there and I want,
and I'm gonna fucking drive over to Atlantic city.
He goes,
oh cool.
All right,
I'll talk to you when we get off.
Right.
So seen him in awhile.
I'm not gonna name any names here cause I don't want to get anybody in fucking
trouble.
Right.
So we get off the fucking,
I get off the plane,
right?
Take a leak to come out,
he's fucking stand.
Hey what's going on?
So we start shooting the shit and we're walking
and we get to the uh,
you know the moving sidewalk.
We hadn't seen each other a little bit and we were standing side by side,
which you're not supposed to cause it's walk or stand.
So this guy as he's walking up,
it's going,
excuse me,
excuse me.
Like he only had to say it once and we immediately immediately got out of the
way.
He comes huff and buys,
he walks by then he points up at the sign that says walk or stand.
So I just was like,
I go,
hey buddy,
relax.
He's walking away.
He goes,
you relax.
I go,
you're the one pointed at the sign.
He started talking more shit.
And I go,
Oh yeah,
I get it.
Yeah,
you got your ear buds in your important.
Right.
So he starts giving me shit and I just start saying it,
turn around every now and then I get a little bit something,
you know,
cause he was listening to and I made him so mad.
He gave me the finger
and it was like the highlight of my fucking trip.
I was already in a bad mood because the second we landed some cont like five
rows back immediately turned on the cell phone and had like a conversation at
the top of his lungs.
You know,
and I know there's something weird about this where in that story than the
middle story,
I was the cont cause I was standing where you were supposed to be walking.
But the thing is the second the guy said,
excuse me,
I knew what I was doing wrong and I immediately got out of the fucking way.
I didn't act,
you know,
I immediately got out of the way.
This guy's still shaking his fucking head.
Ah,
okay.
I was just looking at the guy like,
who the fuck are you to behave like me in that situation?
You know the nervous some people
who you to walk by mad at me that I wasn't aware that you were trying any,
this is the thing.
He really,
even in a fucking
hurry,
cause he had the time to argue with me and gave me the finger.
He's just one of those fucking people that just has to walk fast,
um,
until they feel like they get in somewhere.
I don't know.
By the way,
I gotta tell you something.
Those stupid little fucking little half a straws that people have hanging out of
their fucking ears is just,
you know,
that's like the Bluetooth of headphones.
I think I'm very soon people are going to,
that's going to become like,
remember,
like Bluetooth was cool for like a week evidently.
And then everybody just made fun of that stupid thing hanging out of your ear.
I really think that those,
whatever those things are called,
I have no idea.
It always looks like you have like a little bit,
little straw hanging out of your fucking ear.
Um,
I'm not a fan of those.
I've always been a fan of headphones.
I don't like,
my ears have fucked from playing drums and I don't like jam and shit into my
ear.
MMM.
I Dunno.
Plus,
you know what,
if you ever gotten like bright light tank right there,
what have we gotten to a fight?
Right?
Me and that guy and I fucking threw a hook and I punched him right in the year.
And then that thing goes into his ear,
you know?
And then for the rest of his life,
he's listening to fucking blondie or something in one of his ears.
They can't get it out or punches as ear dramas.
And I get sued,
you know,
all because I wanted to say hello to a comic.
Okay.
Do you understand that people,
that's how quick it can happen.
That's how quickly you can lose your hearing.
MMM.
By the way,
you know what's really fucking underrated?
A Old Lady Card Games.
I sat down with a relative of mine this past week and it was a deck of cards
there,
right?
They had like a little family union
thing.
Right.
And,
uh,
one of my relatives,
she's a little bit older,
whatever.
I was just like,
Hey,
you wanna you wanna play Gin rummy?
And she was like,
yeah,
she proceeded to kick my ass for like the next hour,
but we weren't on our smart phones,
weren't watching TV,
weren't doing anything.
We just sit in there,
you know,
talking about the old days,
laughing,
having a good time,
giving each other shit,
trying to remember how to keep score
and um,
I dunno,
I a guy really got allows sitting there going like,
you know,
that's one of the coolest hangs I've had with this particular relative in a long
fucking time.
Um,
I dunno,
it made me Kinda think like,
you know what,
I should,
I need to bring that into my life.
You know,
my kid's going to be hilarious.
She's going to be like totally have this time.
And then like know how to drive like,
okay,
a Ford f 103 on the tree.
She's going to know how to play Old Lady Card Games.
I forget.
Like I'll,
all this shit that's fucking good from back in the day.
At least.
What I considered,
I'm going to teach her
how to do,
um,
old school shit,
like knowing how to cook as opposed to just doing the Postmates Shit,
you know,
whether she wants to do it or whatever,
she'll know how to do it,
you know what I mean?
Um,
I dunno
and maybe immediately think like,
what if I just converted my entire garage into like a cigar bar and had friends
over over.
We played cards,
I had a smoke eaters so we could smoke inside.
Then I'm like,
well I can't fucking do that because then I'll fucking die of throat and mouth
cancer cause it'll just be too God damn fun.
You know what I mean?
It's weird.
It's a really weird thing being an adult,
you know?
And it's also even more weird figuring it out.
It's 50.
MMM.
Does he have that thing when all of a sudden,
you know,
I guess you go away to college,
you just move out and you're like,
okay,
my parents aren't here anymore.
Now I can do whatever the fuck I want and
you do whatever the fuck you want for awhile.
And then you just start paying for it.
And uh,
I've kind of been learning this really at my age,
there's nothing better then going to bed sober and having eight hours of
uninterrupted sleep.
If I do that
and wake up,
stretch and then go to the gym,
I feel like,
like 15 years younger than I asked.
I feel like I'm in my thirties like it's fucking ridiculous.
Now having said that,
I planned to go back to booze,
you know,
at some point,
but I just,
uh,
I got to get through tape and my special and then there's an outside chance I
have another acting gig coming up and uh,
you know,
cause you never know.
Now Jesus Christ,
you have no fucking idea.
You know,
it used to be back in the day,
if you,
if you were on something this far into where I'm at with this deal,
you were in there.
But in that,
nowadays,
you know,
one fucking tweet or somebody reads some shit from fucking,
somebody pulls out a yearbook from the 80s.
I mean,
you know,
you don't know what can happen.
You don't know what's in there,
you don't,
you don't know what the fuck other people have done.
And all it takes is one principle fucking person.
You know,
there's some fucking,
you know,
VHS tape of him kicking a pigeon in the fucking beacon and then the whole
fucking thing goes away.
So I dunno.
MMM.
So anyways,
there is a thing that I always like,
you know,
I've always wanted to go an entire calendar year,
January 1st through December 31st and not drink and just be like,
I didn't drink that year.
So I think,
yeah.
Uh,
I think this might be the year.
I don't know.
It's already cruising by.
I'm like fucking 11 weeks in already.
You know what's the point is stop.
And by the time I take my special,
that'd be another three weeks.
That's 14 weeks,
52 weeks in a year,
52 minus 1438 weeks to go.
I'm the,
I'm going to,
I can't make it through that.
I think I can do it.
Um,
but anyways,
what the fuck else did I want to talk about?
I'm actually sitting here now late night just at a spot.
And,
uh,
um,
I'm watching showtime boxing.
You know,
it's weird.
I,
I didn't realize HBO,
like let go with a box box,
oops,
sorry.
Boxing after all of these years.
And then on top of that,
uh,
Jim Lampley,
he's gone.
So they still got that Al Bernstein guy or whatever.
I don't know.
But they,
they got all these new announcers and shit.
So it's a weird transition.
You know what I mean?
It's like when you're a kid,
like the voices of it is as big a part as,
as watching it.
So it just takes a while.
Like,
well,
I gotta be honest with you,
like this transition of,
um,
new announcers in the NFL really took me a while.
Um,
and that's why I'm loving Tony Romo cause he's like the greatest,
like,
like all my God,
this guy,
like Tony Romo was still in his thirties,
right?
Like this guy could announce for like another 30 fucking years in the level that
he knows the game is.
This is like,
it's a great thing,
you know,
cause Al Michaels,
I mean,
Al Michaels has gotten blabby what,
like in his seventies,
you know,
and uh,
just those voices that I grew,
I,
I'm so old.
Like I remember the end of curtain Goudy.
Um,
there was,
uh,
pat Summerall and um,
John Madden for the longest time,
dawn crickey,
all of these guys and just,
they have voices.
What?
Just football?
Um,
oh shit.
I should have looked up some more of a,
about what's his face?
He just passed recently to see his face.
He's to host a game show.
Oh my God,
I'm the fucking worst.
The fuck did I forget his name?
I Dunno.
Whatever.
These guys were all the voices of it.
So,
anyway,
so now I'm watching a box in here.
I'm like
enjoying the boxing,
but I'm like,
there's voices.
Like,
who the fuck are these people talking?
Man?
It's just,
it's a weird thing.
You know,
it's like when your favorite band gets like a new lead singer or something.
So let's,
let's say CDC,
somehow ACDC was able to do it.
I don't even know what the fuck I'm talking about.
All I know is this red is right around the time
when I would start doing advertising,
but I don't have any advertising yet.
So let's see,
what else did I want to talk about?
Maybe I'll,
I'll,
I'll record the advertising after.
Maybe I'll do something like that.
Oh,
I got one for you.
I'm watching the boxing by the way.
The boxing.
That's old.
I am.
MMM.
Okay.
I want your boxing in the,
uh,
you know what's funny is the UFC is so fucking destroyed.
This sport fucking destroyed this sport while they were destroying themselves
with the corruption and people ducking fights and just bad decisions and all of
that,
basically throughout my whole fucking life.
But they have so destroyed them.
But you know what's funny,
I shouldn't even bring this up.
It's just funny to me.
Nobody's really paying attention to it.
So like when the ring girls get in the crowd,
there's still all these people going,
whoo,
I'm in fucking whistle in and shit.
Like a fucking bugs bunny cartoon.
They,
all you're do doing is not barking like a dog and stomp on their foot on the
fucking floor.
You know what I mean?
But as I've always maintained,
like when it,
when it comes to this getting offended shit,
that it has to be something big enough that they'll waste their time,
uh,
attaching their wagon.
Oh my God.
Is that far as,
is Larry Merchant gone?
Larry merchant.
I mean Jesus Christ that he,
that guy is like a constant.
MMM.
Yeah.
He,
he,
there was just certain fighters you could tell he just fucking hated them,
you know?
And he would never say anything positive and then he'd go in the ring and start
talking tough.
Like he was going to fucking do something.
MMM.
But I'll miss that guy.
You know,
he had that get off my lawn vibe.
MMM.
But anyways,
I was looking at my,
uh,
my travel schedule for that run that I have that starts in Iceland and ends in
Israel.
Uh Huh.
I have a day off between wherever the fuck I end and then flying over to Israel.
And on that day there's a moto GP race in Spain,
but I just think it's going to be too much to try and get to.
But I really was going to try to catch a fucking racist shit.
I was going to try to go to Austin but um,
my schedules not working out,
but I am so fucking ridiculously excited for Formula One in Moto GP to start
back up again.
This is what gets me through.
It's,
you know,
you got the dog days of summer with baseball.
This is like the dog days before.
I guess it's really just February now cause march madness is next month.
You know,
football's fucking over.
So much madness is next month.
But basketball and hockey,
it doesn't really start fucking matter in until like,
you know,
Jesus Christ,
the beginning of April,
you figuring out who's going to be what seed or whatever.
Uh,
speaking in which congratulations to the Lakers in the last second shot.
Beat my fucking Boston Celtics.
Um,
I dunno what's going on with the Celtics.
I got the stupid fucking do,
they call it the hardwood classic package.
And I,
I've watched like three Bruins games this year in like half a Celtics game over
Christmas.
I've just been so goddamn busy,
it's killing me.
I don't know what's going on.
All I know is we have all his talent on the Celtics and I don't know if they're
underachieving or what,
but like I said,
I was doing that acting Gig last week and one of the guys on the set today,
what's up with Kyrie?
Is he going to go to la?
Um,
so just the fact that he was asking that made me,
uh,
made me a little bit nervous.
Um,
hey,
by the way,
I'm watching this for this Davis Ruiz fight.
Is that I hope though,
that's how you say his fucking name.
And uh,
if I half a second,
I thought it was in Los Angeles,
I was like,
Jesus Christ,
I could have fucking gone to that.
But it's in Carson city,
Nevada.
And I was just thinking that's one of the few cities I've never been to.
You know,
I've been to,
I've been to all the A's,
all the B's in most of the CS c level cities.
Not saying that you city sucks,
it's just,
you know,
there's no professional sports team there.
You know,
there's no traffic is a bit of a math problem.
you know the characteristics of a city city.
You're downtown still.
You can still,
if you squint your eyes,
you're surprised.
Like call younger and Jesse James Aren't walking up the street.
It's still has that,
you know,
wild west look about it.
At least it does out here.
Carson city actually that is the capital of Nevada and I've never fucking been
there.
A lot of people,
if you were to ask them,
hey man,
like what's the Capitol in Nevada?
They would be like,
well,
I would have to say that's Las Vegas.
And if you said no,
they'd be like,
okay,
a fucking Reno.
And you'd be like,
all right,
there's no reason to swear at me.
But no,
it's not reno.
Then they might even guess Loughlin before they would get,
I don't even know where the fuck it is with the Carson city.
I was just south,
just south of Reno.
I Love Reno.
I fucking loved me.
Oh,
there's Lake Tahoe maybe.
I have been in,
I've been to Lake Tahoe.
Jesus Christ said,
I just like pass right through Carson city.
That even fucking realize it.
How the fuck did Carson city ended up being the capital?
This has gotta be like some sort of gold rush,
cowboy shit.
By the way,
there's a movie out called the man who killed Hitler and then the big foot
starring Sam Elliot.
All right.
If you don't fucking immediately try and find out how you can watch that movie.
You are no friend of mine.
It's about a guy,
you know the character.
He's the guy that found Hitler and killed him in World War II and now they're
pulling him out retirement because the big foot,
not big foot,
the big foot,
just like I'm watching the boxing.
All right.
He has to go to Canada and kill the big foot because evidently big foot is
walking around carrying some sort of plague that could wipe out human beings.
So,
and evidently,
I guess big foot is the Hitler of like,
uh,
abominable snowman.
How do you say that fucking word?
I Dunno.
Yeah.
Like what,
what I dunno of Apes.
What fucking world does,
let me look this up right now.
This is,
this is why the feds will never come and pick me up.
They'll never worry.
No matter how much conspiracy theory I say that I might be right about when they
just checked my Google searches here.
Yeah.
They'll just be like,
all right,
this guy is not a threat because of this Google search right now.
What kind of animal,
okay.
Is
Somebody said big bird,
big foot.
I wonder if I'm the first one to ever searched that.
What kind of animal,
big foot or Scotch swatch are said to be Harry Upright walking.
Is it from any sort of family?
You know,
it's,
um,
it's like an eight fucked bill.
Walton is,
as far as I can tell in North American folklore,
big foot or Sasquatch are said to be Harry Upright walking ape like creatures
that dwell in the wilderness and leave footprints.
That's the funny thing about big foot.
What the fuck is that thing ever really done?
Yeah.
It walks around.
Okay.
Is,
you know,
a Sasquatch.
You gotta leave your footprints all over the fucking place.
You know,
it's always running away.
It hasn't really done anything.
That's why I love this movie.
They've somehow found a reason.
Yeah.
For man to finally find big foot and then kill the fucking thing.
All right.
If I was writing that screenplay,
okay.
Big Foot,
having that fucking,
you know,
carrying the plague.
Um,
in the end you would find out that it was all bullshit.
You know,
that it wasn't really doing anything.
It's just where it was walking around.
There was a lot of oil underneath the land where it was walking around.
So
the government then demonize big foot and said that it could take down this
entire first world nation because it's walking around with the fucking,
with scarlet fever.
First of all,
nobody's ever seen big foot.
They don't know where the fuck the thing is.
There's never really been a good picture of the goddamn thing yet.
Somehow they know it has the fucking plague.
All I know is Sam Elliot's in it and I'm going to fucking watch that movie.
Um,
is it in theaters?
You know something.
Can you fuck him?
I still can't believe aqua man made all that money,
mate.
I mean,
God,
I mean happy it did.
I'm happy some movies making some fucking money made 250 fucking million
dollars.
I,
I can't believe people saw that fucking movie.
Aqua man.
He's a superhero in the ocean.
A fish don't commit crimes.
I know you want to go see it.
Yeah.
I didn't see that movie.
What I would do is if I was right now Aquaman,
Aquaman is fucking pissed off because of that swirl a trash out in the fucking
Pacific Ocean and he's fine because he's not really a person is right.
That should be my next Google search.
What kind of fish is aqua Aquaman?
What did aqua man do you know where he is?
Some pirate fucked a mermaid.
Okay.
And that's,
and then the mermaid gave birth to Aquaman.
Alright.
Aqua man grew up without a dad.
It's probably a viking with his blonde hair.
He used to have blond hair anyways.
I don't know.
When I was a kid he had blonde hair and an orange shirt,
you know,
and now he looks like the fucking undertaker
anyways,
undertake his nephew.
So anyways,
I was right in that fucking movie.
Alright.
Some Viking banged in mermaid.
Oh,
who's kid knew historically speaking,
probably raped her.
Right?
So he's the right baby,
have a Viking in a mermaid.
All right,
so his dad's not around and he's a rapist.
So there's no reason to look that guy up.
Plus he's on land,
any his gills,
it can fucking breathe underwater and he sorta speaks through like waves.
So I mean
it's bad enough.
You got to try and fucking,
you know,
call up a rapist on father's date now.
I mean,
you don't really speak,
so how can you communicate with them?
And then the mom,
you know,
sort of shuns him because of obviously how she got pregnant.
So he just sort of fucking,
you know,
he has issues with his mom.
Definitely doesn't like his dad and his dad's really the only land dwelling at
any knows.
So he's just like,
you know what?
Fuck this man.
I don't need anybody.
I'm just going to hang in the ocean with my fish friend.
Right.
Cause Fish,
you know,
they don't fucking judge them or anything.
They take them in like the,
you know,
like the wolf's with the babies that get left out in the woods.
All right.
Just,
just bear with me.
I'm going to get somewhere with this.
So then the fucking guy,
you know,
as he gets older and older and older,
right?
They just stay,
just sitting there.
Uh,
all this trash keeps getting dumped in the ocean and finally he can't fucking
take it anymore.
And he just goes on land and he starts fucking taking people out.
Like Charles Bronson and Deathwish.
All right.
You know,
and like death wish it starts with a rape.
All right,
put in this one.
He is,
he's doing it for the environment and the first people he kills her hoarders.
Well I guess hoarders he likes cause they don't put it,
throw it in the ocean.
You know what I mean?
He'd go after all those people know,
you know,
it fucking kill.
He killed those people that,
that uh,
made that TV show about being minimalists that encourage all these people after
they bought all this shit to just go down and dump it at goodwill and then
goodwill just throws it in the fucking ocean or whatever the fuck it is they do
with it.
You know what I mean?
Um,
man,
all the people I that I thought he was killing,
I really think about it wouldn't kill.
I was thinking about people in storage wars.
He killed them.
He wouldn't,
those people are taken shit that usually get thrown out and they fucking buy it
and they find some stupid fucked up by it.
I think he just hangs out at a goodwill and just people show up at their garbage
bags of shit.
He just fucking takes them and before the cops can get there,
right.
The cops chase him back to the fucking ocean.
You know,
maybe he goes to that swirl of trash and he just find shit and he just goes
through and he finds addresses.
I don't fucking know.
I'll be honest with you.
I didn't even want,
I'm talking about at this point,
I'm just telling you how I would do movies that I never saw.
I don't what,
what the fuck did they do with aqua man?
And then they gave him that chicken of the sea fucking pitchfork.
I didn't understand it.
Is He mad that we're eating tuna?
We're killing all his friends.
You know,
if that's the case,
he should start in Japan.
They're the ones that's doing all the Sushi.
They started that shit.
Right.
See,
I'm trying to get it out of my country.
Um,
all right,
so there you go.
Now I don't know where to go from here because now I only have like a fucking
half hour left.
I still have to do advertising and reads.
Okay.
Um,
you know,
read your question.
So that's what I'll do on Monday.
I'll just bang out the last 25 minutes of this.
Um,
this has been the first half of the podcast,
the ramblings of a lonely man.
Okay.
Who was in a hotel room and he wants to call the front desk,
but there's no information on how exactly I'm supposed to fucking do that.
But it's a good thing because I was going to order food and I'm not fucking
hungry anymore.
All right.
I'm going to watch this God damn fight and through the magic of and time.
Uh,
there'll be no delay on your podcast.
Just know the next time I talk,
uh,
I don't know what it'd be Sunday and Monday.
I know.
Fucking know.
What do you give a shit,
right?
Cause it's going to be a half a second delay field
and just like that.
Now I'm in Los Angeles.
Isn't that amazing?
What an edit can do to you.
That was one second for me.
That was a fucking,
you know,
it's Monday morning.
Um,
I almost feel like I have to do the intro.
So much time has gone by,
by the way.
I believe the last thing I was talking about Saturday,
Saturday deal.
Why don't you fucking come over on Saturday,
Saturday,
say,
um,
now the card game that I played crazy eights or some people call it dirty
eights,
that's just a great fucking game.
And I suddenly realized,
you know,
cause I went over one of my relatives,
uh,
domiciles there and I'm just fucking,
I was just walking around all wound up like I usually am brain going a mile a
minute,
can't fucking shut it off.
You know,
the only thing that I've found that can shut it off is copious amounts of
alcohol or sitting down and smoking a cigar.
Neither of them are good for you.
But I found with cards,
if I just sit down,
there's something about shuffling the car's handling,
the cards gets rid of that energy and I fucking chill out.
And then amazingly enough,
when I play cards,
I have to learn how to control my emotions or else people know what's in my
hand.
I found it very therapeutic.
You know,
the TV wasn't on the entire time I was there and I didn't look at my smartphone
and my head felt clearer.
So I think I learned.
So I think I'm already a scatterbrain
and,
uh,
all the TV screens and phone screens do not help.
Someone like that doesn't help someone like me is my brain's like,
oh,
what about this?
I thought about this.
Well,
I'll fucking look that up.
Oh,
is that what that is?
what does this link to?
Oh,
what,
what does so and so look like now that will surprise me,
you know,
and then I'm just fucking,
there goes two hours of my life and then I'm laying in bed and I can't fucking
get to sleep.
So
I'm going to try to get my wife into playing cards,
although I don't think she's going to do it because she's inherently a chill
person.
And I'm worried that if she starts playing cards,
she might literally not off and fall backwards out of the chair.
Yeah.
But anyways,
oh,
Billy freckles.
All Billy freckles,
79 days,
no fucking booze.
And I'm,
I've got,
I met,
I am getting shit done.
I did a couple of things that I would never do.
I edited two episodes of,
uh,
efforts or family,
went through the script and through in my punchlines,
did it on the fucking plane and there is no way,
all right.
When it's not the off season,
if I'm playing,
if the season has started,
there is no fucking way I would have gotten half of that done.
I would've sat there on the plane,
I would've watched a movie,
I would have had one and I'd be like,
Hey,
I like this failing.
Can we enhance it?
Yeah.
So
I don't know.
Do they have like binge drinker Aa meetings?
You know,
everybody there is just like board,
like,
yeah.
You know,
I could stop,
you know,
I don't need the fucking,
I dunno.
I just named me to a place where they're playing cards or some shit.
Yeah.
Bill.
It's called the casino.
Um,
you don't,
and you don't have to drink.
You can make that choice for yourself.
You can be brave.
You can be a warrior.
He'd be all of these fucking things.
Um,
alright,
hang on a second.
Anyways,
I need to read some of the advertising here for this week here.
Oh,
you know what,
I was coming back from New York City,
so I always get the New York Post.
That's my thing,
man.
I read the post and the Daily News,
but mostly the post cause I like the sports section better.
Um,
I,
uh,
you know,
I was reading this shit,
the Yankees like spring training started and it's so fucking funny,
like the Yankee Mindset,
which is totally George Steinbrenner,
where like we,
we haven't won a world series,
you know,
we lost to the red sox to the honeymoon is over and blah,
blah blah,
blah,
blah.
But there's always a,
there's always this threat,
you know,
with that whatever manager they have a whatever,
there's always this constant pressure that like they have to somehow do the
impossible,
which is to win the way they used to win.
Well,
actually they would accept the way they want in the late nineties,
but um,
I do respect that out of that franchise.
But it's also funny because it's an empty threat.
Like,
what are you going to stop watching?
You know,
we all know we're not going to abandon our teams.
At least the real fans one.
Alright.
Legal Zoom,
everybody.
Legal Zoom.
If you're determined to start a business or secure your family's future in 2019
it's easy to get distracted by hurdles that pop up along the way.
Honey,
would it be okay if we went out to the Whoa,
whoa,
Whoa,
whoa.
That's right.
Whatever you just agreed to,
that's when you would done your fucking will.
Uh,
that's why legal zoom is here to help,
but their network of independent there gunslingers that wild man.
They're out there on their own,
licensed in all 50 states.
How the fuck do you do that?
You've got to take the bar exam 50 times.
Legal Zoom can help you navigate your legal needs.
Full Bill.
Once you are lawyer,
you nearly need to me to fill out an application.
Well,
our build,
they hired 50 lawyers.
Maybe they did that one from each state,
I dunno.
From wills and trusts to LLC trademarks,
contract reviews and Muah.
Legal Zoom has helped
more than flow million people like you take care of their responsibilities and
the best part is,
and you are responsible.
Okay.
Yeah.
You bring a life into this world.
God dammit,
they need to get some cash.
When you fucking face planted a food court,
after you put that last piece of orange chicken and your goddamn pie hole,
and the best part is legal zoom is not a law firms.
So you won't get charged by the hour.
Uh,
make this year,
the year you finally do the right thing for your family.
I'll take the steps you need to take for your small business.
Legal Zoom is here to help so you can focus on what you need to do.
But what you do best make it make a difference in your life.
I hate when I just all of a sudden can't fucking read.
Slow down.
Make a difference in your life this year by visiting legal zoom.com now and for
special savings.
Be sure to enter Promo Code Bar B,
U R R in the referral box at checkout legal zoom where life meets legal.
That's legal zoom.com.
Oh Man.
You know why they went off the rails,
but I crushed it in the end.
Simply safe.
Are you simple and you want to be safe.
We have a solution for you.
So here's a timely stat stat for you.
I'm almost half of us make a new year,
new year's resolution every single year.
We've all made them,
and most of us probably broken.
I'm not me,
man.
I said it wasn't drinking this year and I'm still sober.
I'm better than you happens to the best of us,
but one resolution worth sticking to this year,
keeping your home and family safe.
That's why I recommend simply safe home security.
Evidently,
according to the copy,
I didn't realize that I recommended it.
I thought I'd just read it because they gave me money over there.
Simply safe is a 24 seven home security is 24 seven home security with no
contracts or catch catches.
They believe the safest place on earth should be your home.
So you feel protected every time you shut your door and leave for work or shut
your eyes at night.
How safe this Ted Nugent feel at home?
You know,
he walks around with like a fucking guns strapped to each leg and a crossbow
around his fucking back.
More than three electric.
See,
somebody shoot me when I take a piss in my own house.
More than 3 million people instead of leaves know in his hat,
he probably has like wallpaper,
you know,
so he blends in with his house.
More than 3 million people already feel this way every day,
thanks to simply safe.
And they're not the only ones.
They're not the only ones with home security.
The folks at PC magazine named simply saved both editor's choice in reader's
choice for 2018.
Well,
there you go.
There's a legit magazine,
PC magazine,
um,
2000,
I'd never heard of it.
2019 feels like a good year to ask yourself,
is my home is safe as it could be.
Any of you thinking,
well,
maybe this year or if you're thinking,
maybe this year,
uh,
maybe this is the year to change that fuck call to action.
Get simply safe and just get simply safe.
Just go to simply safe [inaudible] dot com to get started.
That simply safe bird.com to protect your home and family today.
Simply safe birth.com oh,
Jerry's berries.
Why are you bugging,
uh,
talk about your plans for Valentine's Day this year.
What would you do if you weren't procrastinating?
I didn't procrastinate.
I had my wife reach out to somebody of influence and they got us a reservation
at a fucking restaurant that we wouldn't be able to get into if I just called
myself.
Do you know who I am?
I did a half hour comedy central once.
Hello.
Well going to Mcdonald's.
All right.
Um,
share a personal Valentine's Day story.
What are your must gives you gotta get a Ricard.
Okay.
Uh,
you got to get her some flowers.
You got it.
You can't just give her the card and have something that some stranger wrote
for whoever bought the card.
You have to add a paragraph of your own shit
and you have to write that paragraph out on something else.
So when you inevitably have a spelling error or run out of room or something
like that,
you don't do it on the card and then you painstakingly copy it
over to the,
the new card and then you hand at your wife.
She reads it in three seconds and goes,
oh,
okay,
reaches over,
gives you a nice kiss and then looks over your shoulder to see if there's a
package in some sort of heart shape rapping to see if she got some shiny shit so
she can decide at what level she's going to fuck you that night she going to go
through the motions.
Is she going to give you the first three months of your relationship sex or is
she going to take it to another level?
It all depends on whether or not there's a tray of Sherry berries over your
shoulder.
When she goes to hug you,
I mean,
come on people,
do I even need to read the copy after this?
I'll do it just as an exercise in trying to get better on how to re reading out
loud.
Okay.
Um,
never go wrong with the,
um,
with their signature dipped valentines strawberries dipped in milk,
dark or white chocolatey goodness for any discerning palate.
She'll fall in love with every bite.
Stop cheating on a talk with decadent toppings,
chocolate chips,
heart and glitters sprinkles,
honey,
I have to admit I'm having an emotional affair.
Was Sherry's berries,
always fresh,
always tasty,
always worth the wait,
perfect companion to a candlelit dinner,
a bouquet of flowers or a night on the town Valentine's made easy.
Arise fresh with 100% Sherry's berries.
Guarantee ships anywhere nationally.
Gives sweet somethings to your long distance.
Love Valentine's Day is just a few days away.
Send her a Valentine's Day gift of her dreams at the price of your dreams,
starting at just 1999 plus shipping and handling plus.
Order now and make this Valentine's Day really special by getting double the
berries for just $10 more.
Go to Barry's dot Com B e r r,
I e s.com.
Click on the microphone and enter my code at checkout.
That's B e r r,
I e s.com.
Click the microphone and enter
Code Bar Order today.
Hey,
what do you do if your,
if your girlfriend,
you know is getting a little hefty there,
you don't want to get in chocolate covered strawberries.
Can you just get her to the strawberries too?
They have an a la carte strawberry,
maybe a,
a uh,
a chocolate covered Brussels sprout a stamps.com stamps.com is the fastest and
more convenient way to get postage.
You want me hilarious as if your girlfriend got you Rogaine for fucking
Valentine's Day.
Simply use your computer to print official US postage for any letter,
any package,
any class of mail,
anywhere you want to send.
And the mail carrier picks it up.
No more lugging the mail to the post office.
You know,
heavy envelopes are no more hassles,
man.
With stamps.com you get discounted postage rates that you can't even get at the
post office.
Not to mention it's a fraction of the cost of those expensive postage meters.
Oh
and there's no equipment to Lisa.
No longterm commitments.
I use stamps.com anytime I sent out my posters,
I'm a fucking moron.
If I can do it all as oak in you and right now you too can enjoy the stamps.com
servers with a special offer that includes a four week trial plus postage and a
digital stay at scale.
So start the new year off,
right.
Go to stamps.com click on the microphone at the top,
the homepage and type in bird that stamps.com enter burr are right now.
Let's get to,
let's fucking read them.
May Yo,
let's fucking read the mail.
All right.
From reddit Los Angeles then and now follow up.
I love that someone gave me this here cause I'm going to go back to reading
books now.
Like I read a lot of them,
but like I really think that my brain does not do well.
Watching a bunch of shows and screens and stuff.
I just,
I find I'm going to go,
I'm going to do some old people.
Shit.
I'm going to play cards.
I'm gonna complain to the local,
my local representative about the sidewalk Kevin and cracking it or whatever the
fuck old people do.
Branding or whatever.
I'm going to read some books.
We'll see.
Um,
there are a lot of,
my,
my favorite things to do those with Reader's digest is to read the awful jokes
to my wife.
And I know that that's a Jim Norton bit back from the Opie and Anthony Show.
But I feel like if I do it in my bedroom,
I'm not stealing from him.
Maybe I'll give them credit next time.
He used to read the comics was one of my favorite bits that he would do.
Um,
then the local news,
the newspaper,
daily comic,
sorry.
There are a lot of books on Los Angeles history.
Ah,
this person writes,
I find the whole,
the whole thing fascinating.
Why am I so much?
Okay.
Uh,
even thought it's history even though it even thought,
even though person wrote thought,
even though it's history isn't as long as Boston,
Philly in New York,
the whole thing is fascinating.
Um,
let me see.
They said I made an album or this go to the page.
I would like to see this.
Let's see.
Oh yeah,
look at the old,
oh my goodness.
Look at these old houses.
Holy Shit.
They just knocked all of this shit down,
didn't they?
Oh many times.
Must stay.
Plow it fucking over.
You know,
a lot of old houses.
They just had that creepy fucking look.
But these are credible and you don't want to just realize you guys can't see
them.
All right,
let's get back to whatever the fuck it was.
I was reading,
um,
bad highlights.
Just how,
okay.
Okay.
I met an album that highlights just how true bill's bulldoze everything is.
La destroyed an entire historic neighborhood downtown to force the poor from the
city center and build more economically viable skyscrapers.
One of the darkest blemishes in Las history.
And that's not the only,
that's not the,
all the wall on the amount of neighborhoods destroyed and people displaced due
to freeway construction is astronomic and is estimated at 300,000 people were
displaced between 1940 and 1974.
The freeways,
which pretty much destroyed the history.
This historic city explains why La is more suburban,
uh,
than cities San Francisco.
Yeah.
It's fascinating how they do all that stuff.
You know,
there's eminent domain,
which means while we're building this freeway,
you can take this money for your house or we'll just fucking take it from you.
Um,
I try not to get too sad about it.
I just look at it like,
you know,
when those historic neighborhoods were being built,
there was native Americans crying going,
you know,
we used to fucking sit there and,
uh,
I dunno.
Skin of Buffalo,
whatever the fuck it.
I don't,
I don't know what the fuck.
You know,
there's always going to be somebody that you know,
you know what used to be there,
so I don't know.
Get a deck of cards and shut off your fucking TV and maybe you can have a nice
20 minutes to yourself.
All right,
advice from Mormon at Byu.
Um,
hey there ability nickname.
Uh,
last week on your podcast,
you read a letter from a Mormon attending Byu asking for advice about leaving
the church as a former Mormon.
That's a great former Mormon.
Hi,
I'm Mike Mormon.
I'm a former Mormon.
Keep it going for the former Mormons who also grew up in Utah.
I thought I could only offer a little advice for them.
I thought I could offer a little advice to them.
I also went through something similar when I was 19 I told my parents I wasn't
going to go on a mission,
which is a huge rite of passage in the Mormon religion.
Oh my God.
They must've been crushed and then you've got to deal with upsetting the two
people that you want the most approval approval from.
They were really upset about it and it was hard for me to do,
but I couldn't lie to myself anymore and try to believe in what the church
teaches.
Not long after that,
I moved out of my parents' house and started attending the University of Utah in
Salt Lake City.
It seemed daunting at the time and I didn't know.
I didn't think I would be able to afford it,
but somehow was able to do it.
Good for you.
The hardest part about leaving the church is that all that the other members
will ask you a million questions about why you're leaving and they're always
trying to convince you to come back.
Obviously you can't shut out your family completely,
but if you don't believe in what the Church teaches,
then you're not doing yourself any favors by staying just because it's routine.
Take it from me.
I left the church a long time ago and I don't regret it.
The people I know who have regrets are the ones I went to high school with,
stay in the church,
went on missions,
gotten married in the temple and ended up leaving Mormonism.
Anyway.
Uh,
they all say that they would do things differently if they had to do it over
again.
The Mormon church isn't going anywhere.
It will always be there.
If you eventually decided to go back,
decided to go back,
but you'll never get your time back if you decide to stay in the church and then
ended up regretting it.
I hope this helps and I'm sure you'll meet people who feel the exact same way
you do.
I've met tons of them and they really helped me out anyways,
as always.
Thanks and go hug yourself.
Wow.
Yeah.
I imagine if you know,
if you looked for some sort of support group online,
you could probably find a way to do that.
And I like what he said.
The church is always going to be there.
You can always come back,
you know,
or you know,
maybe you enjoy it as much as this guy does and you stay out.
There you go.
It's your life.
You choose.
All right,
advice from Warman.
Here we go.
Here's another one,
dear Billy bow,
B a.
L.
Look it up.
All right.
Was this Mormon football bag?
Let's see.
B,
a L.
Mormon word.
How many times ball.
Okay.
All right.
What the fuck is this?
This is some deep religious shit here.
Bible dictionary.
B,
a l,
possessor Lord.
The Sun God in the mail or,
hmm.
Generative principal in nature.
He was worshiped with different ideas and rights in different places.
So it's a possessor.
Lord.
The Fuck is a possessor.
Is that a landlord for Jesus?
I don't.
I don't even know what that means.
This is why I,
why I just try to keep my life simple.
Cause even if I don't know a word,
if I look it up,
I still don't know the word.
All I'm left with is more questions.
Just wanted to chime in on the advice that she gave that kid at Byu.
Okay,
good.
Cause I didn't think I gave him good advice.
I had no idea what I,
whatever.
I grew up Catholic on the east coast and converted to Mormonism when I was 18
then a year later I left my top 20 college to serve a mission in Las Vegas.
You went to Las Vegas to try and convert people.
Jesus Christ.
You dove in with both feet.
Yeah.
Can I just talk to you for a second about Mormonism?
Some guy sitting at a blackjack table,
he's on a roll or even worse,
he's fucking losing.
When I got back,
my school wouldn't take me.
I was in a music program for drums and hadn't practiced in two years,
so I'd hope to go to Byu for a year and build my chops back up before I could
get back into my original program.
Wait a minute.
What do you mean?
In what way would the fuck does your school not take you?
I was a grew up Catholic.
He converted Mormonism.
You left your top 20 colleges to serve a mission in Las Vegas?
When I got back my school wouldn't take me.
Oh.
So I had to go to Byu,
uh,
for a year and build my chops back up before I could get back into my original
program.
Ah,
cause you haven't played drums in two years.
All right.
I got married in the church and because my parents weren't members they couldn't
go to the ceremony in the temple.
What we did have a separate ring ceremony from my friends and family is the
marriage in the temple is usually small with a little pomp and circumstance.
Um,
I can't think of anything that I've heard that has hurt my parents as much as
the decision that I had made surrounding my beliefs.
The long talks,
the arguments,
the crying,
the pain of not around their sun,
et cetera.
It was very hard on my family.
Through all of that though,
they want me to be happy and want me to be me.
We are closer now than we have ever been having worked through our differences.
Your parents should always love and support you.
Well,
it depends on what you're doing
it all.
If you're going to go rob a liquor store,
shoot some heroin.
I don't think they should love and support well,
they could say no and a loving supporting.
When while I was at Byu,
there was a student in my program that took his life because he didn't like the
lifestyle of the church and was scared of what his parents would think.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Haven't spoken to his parents after his death.
They would rather have their son alive and out of the church than dead and in
the church.
Wow.
It will be hard,
but don't ever feel like there is no way out and no way that and no one that has
your back be why you can make you feel that way.
Begin to talk with your parents about it now and share how you feel about
yourself.
They will be hurt but still love you.
Eat a Dick Bill.
Get some meat on those bones.
You skinny bitch.
I love on it.
You know,
if I'm fat,
I'm fat.
If I'm skinny,
I'm too skinny.
I just can't make you people happy.
Ooh.
Um,
all right.
What do we got here from a masculine lesbian lady?
Oh,
I put it out there,
you know,
Valentine's Day was coming up,
is coming up.
You need all the pressure's always on the guy and we have to show how much we
love them and they really don't have to do shit other than put on something hot
and bang you and they act like they're doing you a favor when sex feels good to
them too.
So I don't really don't understand,
you know?
Can you imagine if I acted like,
you know,
banging my wife was,
was this great pleasure thing for her is I'm on top of her like,
ah,
Eh,
like I'm not having a good time and those are the noises I make during sex.
And you could fucking deal with that for the rest of the day.
Have that in your head.
Ah,
eh.
that's what I do on a loop,
on a loop,
um,
from a masculine.
So I asked,
you know,
I want to talk to the man in the lesbian them with a more manly woman in the
lesbian relationship.
Does what does she have to do?
You know,
cause it's two ladies there right now.
Do you both demand shit or there's one,
you know the one who has to go up on the fucking roof during the reign to fix
the fucking,
you know,
Goddamn,
uh,
the,
the fucking satellite dish,
right?
So anyways,
hey,
Yo,
I came Billy bibbet city,
the bass city.
I've got another word I have to look up.
I have no idea.
Where do you guys,
where do you guys hear these fucking words?
I know I can't spell.
I know I'm fucking stupid
now,
but bad.
Usually uncountable.
Uh,
the practice or habit of drinking too much alcohol.
Oh my God,
I love this word.
How do you pronounce it?
Pronunciation.
Is it [inaudible]
come on,
let me hear.
Let me hear it.
Okay.
Then nationally,
how do you say it?
They eventually [inaudible] Sally say bye.
[inaudible] all alright.
Ay.
Yo Billy verbosity.
Wow.
Visit this.
This,
this person's a thinker.
Although I think you are back on the wagon of,
of late.
Yes,
I am.
Um,
I had been a fan of yours.
Wait,
am I going to look that word up again with,
I already forgot what it means.
It Booze Hound,
right?
Hmm.
The [inaudible] the practice or habit of drinking too much alcohol.
Um,
somebody who Bose is,
that's a great name for a band.
It's a great name for a podcast.
Uh,
Billy verbosity.
I don't know if he can beat that.
That's a great wrestling character.
He's drunk.
He can't hear the ref.
Um,
I have been a fan of yours,
uh,
going on a decade now.
You're literally my favorite comedian all the way back to punching the muffins
in the,
at the flea market.
My flip and favorite.
Ah,
God bless you.
Uh,
you put out the call for a masculine lesbian lady to right.
So here's your ear.
Fall.
First off,
I have no idea what it's like to be a man.
All I know is that I can relate to so many of your jokes and rants about the
dynamics between men and women from the man's side.
Isn't it refreshing to hear a woman say she actually doesn't know what it's like
to be a man.
So many of these fucking assholes.
I know exactly what it's like.
It's easier.
Um,
I've,
you're,
you're a cartoon character.
I've been married to my lovely wife for 21 years.
The first nine illegally until same sex marriage became legal in Massachusetts.
Uh,
when we legalized our vows.
Congratulations.
Uh,
in our relationship,
I am the bread winner.
The fixer of all broken things.
The killer of scary bugs for sure.
The one who would have to climb on the roof and fix the damn 10 and the rain.
Barring that,
the one that's got to negotiate with the servicemen,
while she nudges me and says,
just pay him,
I'm missing my show.
The one who pays for dinner,
even when I'm the,
the celebrated,
the list goes on.
Oh my God.
Jesus Christ.
Could I have a beer with you further?
I am expected to ensure my lovely wife is wowed on Valentine's Day,
our anniversary and her birthday.
I make good money.
Don't get me wrong,
but my gosh,
I liked that you already said flipping in my,
my,
are you a card player?
Deeplake old lady cards.
Crazy eights.
Um,
what the hell am I ended on?
My Gosh,
I mean,
in fairness she puts up with my material attitude,
circular debating and occasional raging.
Wait,
is somebody trolling me right now?
Is this the lesbian version of me still?
I have no,
but I don't say my gosh still,
I have no doubt that I would be cut in half if we,
we divorced also,
no doubt she'll outlive me.
Wellbeing,
such a brave widow,
lol.
Uh,
before I get all Rodney Dangerfield on you,
no respect.
I'll tell you no respect at all.
Uh,
in truth,
we are the best of friends all the way back to our first day in high school.
She understands me more than anyone in my life and it's truly help push me
forward in my career in ways I never thought possible.
Win-Wins.
See,
now as a man,
I don't think I could ever admit that about my wife.
Maybe that's the flaw.
Uh,
she's funny without trying and brilliantly smart and honest.
She helps me be a better person.
Wait,
did near right this and she's pretending to be a lesbian.
Um,
yeah.
As a woman of a certain age,
49,
I came up at a time when dynamics between same sex relationship and had the male
female polarity IX expectation attached.
I don't think it's as much that way now.
So much has changed in the Lgbtq culture since we were coming up.
Lesbian,
gay,
Bi,
Trans Queer.
I don't like fuck,
I can't something else.
I have to look up.
I can never remember how that goes.
Lgbtq,
yeah.
Um,
then back then
the old man voice,
back in my day,
the term butch fem was hugely popular and I am definitely more butch.
It's also a regional identity associated more with the east coast and the West.
We've lived out west for over a decade and don't see a whole lot of butch.
Slash.
Femme,
I dunno,
but for that matter we're not nearly as social as we were back east.
So who knows?
You should totally do a study on butches.
We are.
We are a good lot.
Hope that helps and go fuck yourself to do you realize how fucking hilarious it
was?
It would be in a perfect world.
You went into a bar after having a fight with your wife and some
dude in the lesbian relationships,
sort of old school chick was sitting there at the bar and you both fucking hit
it off.
Okay.
Be fucking hilarious.
MMM,
I see.
I think that's just how it is.
I just think in maybe all relationships,
there's just,
there's the person that's fucking pulling the wagon and then there's a person
sitting in the wagon complaining.
Um,
you know,
but when you stop the,
they rub your back.
I don't,
I don't fucking know any dilemma,
dear Billy,
for in the road.
Is it supposed to be fork in the road?
That's for dear Billy.
For in the road.
If you had to choose between,
I think it's fork in the road.
If you had to choose between being president of the United States or pope of the
Catholic Church,
which would you choose and why?
Oh,
president.
Because I only would have to make evil decisions for most eight years and at the
least four years,
that's why I would do it.
They're both absolutely horrific jobs and the amount of blood on your hands at
the end of it is,
um,
I don't think it's something you ever get past if you're a truly normal human
being.
And I don't,
but that's why I don't think normal human beings go for their job.
Go for those jobs.
All right.
Um,
and there's a lot of people,
you know,
especially in politics,
they put on the fucking white hat and they act like they're there for you.
Some of them are,
but they're always,
they're always now labeled as Socialists and working for,
you know,
isis or the Russians or whatever,
and they just get buried.
Um,
you know,
I dunno,
you watched,
you watched that,
that,
that young woman there,
that 29 year old woman who everybody's just flipping out about for whatever
reason,
because she's young and pretty.
I don't know why everybody's freaking out about her.
She has very little experience and everybody is freaking out.
Like she's fucking amazing.
They,
one of the things that she wanted to do was tax certain American 70% and it's
just like it taxing anybody more than 50% is fucking criminal.
The fact that you're doing the job,
you actually get up and do the job and then somebody who didn't do the job gets
more fucking money than that is fucking criminal.
And watching this woman just sitting there,
you know,
talking to these old politicians and acting like she's sitting there with the
two by four and it's going to start cleaning shit up and she's completely
ignoring the $800 billion gorilla in the room.
Completely fucking ignoring it.
Okay.
And she's going to few,
you watch all her righteousness and all her fucking bullshit.
I guarantee you.
Guess who's going to be a multimillionaire at the end of her political career,
even if she doesn't advance past the senator or House of representative level
where she only makes six figures a year,
guess who's going to be a multimillionaire sign a massive book deal,
totally fucking sellout and buy a big ass fucking house and maybe doing an arena
tour like Michelle Obama or go on a speaking tour like every other fucking
president you watch and go,
they ain't going to talk to you.
They're going to go out and talk to banks and corporations and everyone who
finance their fucking campaigns.
You fucking watch.
All right.
Okay.
You saw what happened when Trump tried to pull the troops out of Syria.
Both Democrats and Republicans were 100% against that and they act like we can,
we can't disbelieve already displaced all these people,
but the,
but they don't give a fuck.
That's their money.
That money for being in that fucking bullshit over there.
That fucking shit right there is what makes them fucking millionaires,
multi,
multi fucking millionaires.
And all they do is sit there and blame each other and every mouth breathe and
fucking moron fucking just believes it,
drinks the Koolaid and then goes on Facebook and starts arguing with each other
and then starts advocating to tax a fellow American who didn't get us into those
wars upwards of 70 fucking percent.
That's the direction we're going to go in.
And it,
no,
and at no point are we ever going to examine the banking system or are we going
to look at corporations and see how they can be reeled back into actually being
less powerful than the United States government or whatever country that they're
in.
All right.
That's the world you enter as president or pope.
Pope of the Catholic Church,
Catholic fucking church.
I mean,
I mean one of the biggest fucking terrorist organizations ever,
ever.
The amount of fucking people that they tortured and murdered.
I mean,
they were in bed with the Nazis.
They were hiding one in the Nazis in their fucking churches.
One of the guys,
one of the fucking,
you know,
PR people,
part of the final solution that the we side was hunting down was founded a
fucking Catholic church in the south of France.
Dead Jewish people's gold.
They had some of that in the church and they had to fucking give that back.
I mean,
it's a fucking shit show.
So if you get there,
that is a lifetime appointment.
And if you think you're going to go in there and change that when everybody else
in their previous to you has all that blood on their hands,
like they're not going to view you as a threat.
Um,
yeah,
it was,
which was funny when Trump came in,
he's like,
I'm going to clean up the swamp.
Let's just say he actually did have a good heart and he wasn't like the fucking
Grinch.
Let's just say actually did have a good heart.
Um,
that whole thing.
I'm going to clean up the swamp.
Like everybody there who was corrupt was going to be like,
well,
I guess the party's over.
He's going to clean it up.
No one's going to work with you.
No one's going to help you cut their own fucking head off.
So,
um,
I dunno,
I don't want to end on a depressing note,
but like that is,
it is a massive,
massive,
massive fucking
problem.
Um,
it's the reason why there's global warming.
It's the reason of overpopulation.
All of it goes back to corrupt politician and religion.
And that's as far as I can tell and I'm not as smart guy.
You might know it better than me,
but there is no fucking reason why we um,
shouldn't be polluting much less.
I was just reading something where like the continent of Africa is going to feel
the effects the first,
which is the worst fucking continent for that to happen too,
because with racism and third,
the way people view the so called Third World countries and everything,
nobody's gonna give a fuck until it's in their fucking backyard and it's going
to be fucking too late.
So there you go.
There's one to grow on.
And that's why I fucking have gone back to reading reader's digest,
looking at those dumb jokes,
just playing cards and sitting on my back porch,
smoking a cigar,
staring at a fucking tree because
we're on a runaway fucking train and everybody and everybody who was a passenger
on the train is blaming everybody else on the other side of the aisle as if
they're the ones driving the fucking train.
Oh my God,
this is depressing.
Anyways,
that's the podcast.
God bless you.
It's almost baseball season.
Take me out to the ball game.
I just realized the volume was up super loud because I just took this mix around
in my luggage.
I hope this wasn't too distorted.
Uh,
God bless you.
I'll check in on you on Thursday.
You cuts.